[Music]
so I came out of this movie with a big
old grin on my face like cheese and hard
you know I just felt really good about
stealing you make it look good but no
just like seeing this new group of women
together it just felt good you know what
I'm saying I came out and I was like oh
we kind of do you know what I'm saying
like did it feel is good to be on set
with all of you all as it let me look it
did yeah tell me no no you don't it
always takes a while to get into the
groove of anything you don't know if
someone's gonna be comfortable working
one way or another way orgonite gonna
improv can we not you know and after
after the first couple of weeks
everything just kind of settled just
settled yeah yeah yeah and you realized
there wasn't one person who didn't want
the other one to succeed right and once
you realize that if you get around those
people who don't want you to succeed you
can feel it feeling there wasn't anyone
on the set that didn't want their
counterparts to know everybody yeah you
know that's in everyone's everyone's
clark's you know a Helena with her
charcuterie anyone you know so little
traveling she's a little traveling carry
baggage that was worried that we're all
starving night shoots yeah can't bring
me tray so we've all heard from I think
every single one of you about this
infamous group text who started the
group text do you know we we're not
quite sure I'm not quite sure but now
we're worried about being hacked so
Marie Ginobili yes it's all delicious -
laughs as I said let's just go through
the run last night we read through all
our texts to each other remember that
moment we said Angela made us delete
them all there really no longer exists
hackers you no longer exist no there's
actually probably pretty smart I was
gonna ask you if it still exists but now
I know the answer
we don't always exist just not hard to -
yes notes lip-reading in telepathy yeah
okay so you guys have so many fans we
went to the fans to ask what they wanted
to ask you if they had any questions and
we picked our football so I have one and
of course I had it on an iPad but
Entertainment Tonight we're high budget
and it didn't work so I had to put it on
my phone I whined all right so it's just
a little okay oh it's someone's voice I
want to know oh oh has actually stolen
something in their life on the spot
that's you stolen something in their
life I'm definitely stolen tampons I see
yes when I was a teenager I stole your
tempo you so much I don't even need one
I would say yes okay well yes yes I can
yes I can I do I was young I was young
and I didn't know any better I did I did
I did for was a candy bar it was a candy
bar in the candy it was in a candy cane
yeah always in the candy family was in
the candy family did you sold stolen
nothing I know I don't
I'm I stole these shoes far away on the
rolls nice to risk we go with the
porridge that they gave you this is
feeling is there anything stealing that
grade or someone arrest gray area walked
up to another table and stolen their
bread in a restaurant that's a really
important stuff are you I know that like
open the bargaining than you oh my god
have you stolen anything
I mean stolen hugs I'll hit it again
yeah that's it there's only one fancy
like how black I had the money they
hadn't even know yet was okay so you
guys were so much great jewelry what is
the most expensive piece of jewelry that
you've ever been loaned and what would
you have done like if you lost it hmm I
dunno
what would I done lost I probably gone
to jail yeah you taking sure no I treat
ya know I think you have to it's you to
sign that terrifying thing saying that
if you you know you lose it yes college
education I think you know what I'm not
gonna wear these I wore I wore something
that was a 25 carat diamond and then I
was like don't give me like two nipple
rings that works so you didn't see them
so was it worth it that's what you
question saw the outline I did it was
like in like a at that time I was like 4
million or something there were there's
two guys following me oh my god they
were following you go you want to do
what is it just put on a cord they went
a court it's a yellow black shiny corn
it just was it is I've run of the most
expensive toe rings from targets and I
I'm really up there and I don't lose
them because I'll make sure they're
strapped on put some tape on them some
strings okay pick a particular and I'll
put the pedicure rack just to make sure
just to make sure they're sturdy that's
why our days were it was well this is
all about civilian from a star so if you
could steal from another celebrity's
closet who would that be and and why
would you steal but it would would they
would their size then shift to my side
okay that's adding roles
I would steal everything she had a
minute can't shoes she's the dresser
ever she's brilliant
my underwear oh my god it's ugly oh okay
yeah no they do not want to vote don't
hate Lynch and his granny panties under
that video up until recently I still
have this series something you want on
just wondering why he hates being filmed
okay want this to be yeah just a hurry
[Laughter]
no she does not
thank you mm-hmm okay so maybe once
anyone closet you can take I would I
would have to dip into Kate's a little
bit and I would nor that no I think
tonight pieces I have something right
these great pieces that she brought in
some great pieces I brought a little bit
of Gwyneth Paltrow's class oh that's a
good one yeah um I would I would I like
to mix it up and then so like a little
bit of the rock and roll I like a little
bit of the classic right I like I was
like I would like um Karl Lagerfeld's
closet oh yeah I would like [ __ ] oh
oh yeah fire I was talking about you
know hey I know I have to wrap up but
but quickly the first oceans was a
trilogy
so actually Roshan petrology was essence
was just 11 right yeah there you go
oceans with Sinatra yeah yes the very
first so the Clooney oceans was a
trilogy so we expect more movies miss
executive producer I think I think if
there isn't is a successful outcome
mm-hmm and there is a successful next
script and a successful group of
individuals that are eager to be a part
of another successful ride and I think
it would be a nice thing
I'm very successful that's a very Debbie
answer thank you